hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einer neuen
episode whatsapp sales die letzte folge
kam mega gut bei euch an deswegen habe
ich mir gedacht ich mache noch eine
folge ja ich würde sagen gestalten mit
dem ersten mods entfällt und zwar ist
ein englischer bortfeld und zwar
schreibt eine person das an seine
freundin und zwei bruder you doing seine
freundin antwortet massing much einem
rallye teil des going to sleep and you
und er antwortete daraufhin die klubs
training
[Musik]
das ist der nächste wort fällt uns
vorschreibt eine person an seine oma
namens hanna die nachricht ich habe
gehört du hast jetzt ein smartphone ruft
mich an wenn du hilfe brauchst ich hoffe
es geht dir gut liebe grüße franz i
daraufhin antwortet die oma flitton zv
dann noch das hier also einfach gar
nichts und dann noch das hier also auch
gar nix und der antwortete traten sie
auf jeden fall mach dir keine sorgen
übung macht den meister und omaha
antwortete daraufhin niedersachsen
apropos an niedersachsen
also an alle unter euch die
niedersachsen wohnen zum zeiten der
aufnahme sind die schulen war ich noch
nicht nicht
aber habt ihr wahrscheinlich abreißen
verdammt nochmal samstag luca
aber ihnen die machen ja gar alle
bundesländer ihre schulen zu für die
nächsten wochen also ähnlich wird es
besonders von niedersachsen traf
siebenmal stand jetzt sind in
niedersachsen die schule noch nicht zu
so schreibt es ja gern mal die
kommentare allerdings ist das hier der
nächste box empfängt und zwar schreibt
dort alles einer person also alles ist
so ein telefon
sprachen lernen da das ist irgendwann
telekommunikationsunternehmen glaube ich
auf jeden fall schreiben die der person
hat so eine standardisierte nachricht
lieber alles kunde wir haben ihre sim
karte gesperrt bitte setzen sie sich mit
uns in verbindung ihr altes team
daraufhin antwortet die person warum
worden ich glaube alles bezahlt bekommen
ich habe früher auch immer der telekom
beantwortet wenn die gesagt haben die
datenvolumen ist leider auf geburt war
hoch was jetzt der nächste weizenfeld
und verschreibt eine frau ich habe
gelesen dass ich als frau fünf jahre
länger leben als du als mann daraufhin
antwortet ihr mann gott schreibt euch
die zeit gut die ihr beim einparken
verschwendet
ja
könnt ihr mal wieder kommentieren die
auch die ich heute klatschen durch
manchmal auch beim nächsten mal
beschreibt eine person seinem kollegen
seinen lauf abend und er schreibt alter
ich habe gestern eine liter wodka
gesoffen bin gerade mit dem mädel im arm
auf einer couch in irgend einer wg
aufgewacht habe den kater meines lebens
und das einzige was die im kühlschrank
haben ist bier und sein kumpel antwortet
einfach ich verstehe dein problem nicht
[Musik]
beim nächsten motzfeld schreibt eine
mutter eine nachricht an ihre tochter
nadine und zwar hallo leertaste nadine
leertaste ausrufungszeichen leertaste
großbuchstaben bass leertaste macht
leertaste leertaste leertaste die
leertaste uni fragezeichen
hallo mama das ist die spracheingabe du
brauchst leerzeichen nicht sprechen das
macht die app selbst
ich gucke brief erbse ritalin mama bitte
auf damit und immer deine nachricht
wir hatten so einen ähnlichen wurzeln
fällt schon mal ich weiß gar kein
notfall sondern eine aber und das habe
ich damals auch schon gesagt meine
mutter ist genauso nur meine mutter
nutzt einfach diese funktion dass man
nicht sprachnachrichten schickt seine
voice sondern dass dies ein spricht und
dann schlägt der text möglich
sprachnachrichten also voll viele von
meinen freunden regen sich immer
auffällig die eine minutenlange
sprachnachricht schicke aber ich denke
einfach nur so da kann man viel mehr
information reinpacken man kann witze
oder ironie viel besser rüberbringen
ich finde es toll weil man kann es
irgendwie anhören wenn man gegen grad am
essen ist oder keine ahnung was macht
also seid ihr sprachnachrichten fan oder
hasst ihr sprachnachrichten eure meinung
ist gefragt in der umfrage hier oben
oh mein gott ich könnte auch so ein
werbe sprecher verwalter schreibt
deutlich egal morgen in in was okay da
genau ok abgemacht doppelpunkt de
ausrufezeichen drei fragezeichen
krass dass die jetzt what's up dad
verlauf mit sandra drin haben also
wirklich keinen spaß freunde sandra ist
die schlimmste was solche nachrichten
angeht die schreibt die will dir einfach
sagen ey kannst du mir eine pizza
bestellen da muss die zehn nachrichten
zu schreiben und dann immer ein wort
dann verschreibt sie sich dann
korrigiert sie das wort dann hat
irgendwas von menschen nicht gesehen
ziemlich harten mann meine welt ist
zerstört was warum was ist los ich weiß
nicht ob ich weinen oder lachen soll
warum benjamin blümchen und chuck norris
haben den gleichen deutschen synchron
[Musik]
benjamin blümchen und chuck norris haben
den gleichen synchronsprecher was ich
brauche noch einen augenblick nicht zu
hause bin alles okay ja klar alles gut
deine eltern haben den mädchen russin
mitgebracht die sind seit heute
nachmittag beschäftigt und nicht einmal
aus ihrem zimmer gekommen was haben
meine eltern mitgebracht die
autokorrektur wie sie leibt und lebt
launchen ich habe gestern gesehen welche
pin-nummer du beim geldautomaten ein
gegeben hast ja ja schon klar und wie
lautet die 72 34 a falsch 56 34
das
könnte tatsächlich auch sandra sein
es ist irre
sandra ist einfach jeder whatsapp welche
front machen pharao man was ist los habe
gerade meinen vater aber halt so ein
herz mal die geschrieben dann hat er mir
eine 3 mit einer eckigen klammern
zurückgeschrieben und sagte das ist ein
kurzen dahinter ich fühle mich irgendwie
missverstanden
wenn ihr euren eltern ihnen die imo
schickt und ihr wissen damit nicht
richtig umzugehen beziehungsweise nicht
im auto sondern halt irgendwie so
doppelpunkt bindet kann man dann fragen
ja irgendwie heraus zumal ja ich habe
die volle punktzahl im english test das
kann nicht sein doch du hast keine
minute dafür gelernt wie willst du das
geschafft haben klar habe ich gelernt
ich habe die letzten wochen big bang
theory und how i met your mother auf
englisch geguckt respekt und ich bin
ganz ehrlich ich habe durch das
anschauen von englischen youtube-videos
oder englische serien mehr englisch
gefühlt gelernt als in zwölf jahren
schulunterrichts horsten schreibt ich
muss samstag doch arbeiten jetzt ist
krank geworden tut mir echt leid und
daraufhin antwortet seine freundin acht
nicht so schlimm da kann ich samstag in
aller ruhe während du bei der arbeit bis
zum hinterher gehen wir noch joggen
daraufhin antwortete thorsten heck und
seine freundin antwortete sie ich meinte
natürlich bügeln hast du die beiden
körbe mit bügelwäsche im schlafzimmer
nicht gesehen
autokorrektur kann ein richtiger engel
sein manchmal so oft der schulter aber
manchmal so ein richtiger teufel
ich habe einen orden verdient für meine
vergleiche was gc juha dggg gdl was
heißt hdg gdl hat sich ganz ganz ganz
ganz ganz doll lieb vsmk nbbl sgm nad m
was heißt das denn mädchen komm mal klar
ich war besoffen letzten samstag die mir
nicht auf die nüsse bist voll gemein
ganzen abkürzung mit den buchstaben auch
immer früher was gab es da noch
i love you and aus wirtheim das eminent
ist rod special take it with us
intensiver kuss und intimität des tvh
was warum schreibst du nicht gleich auf
deutsch
welcher dass miley dachte auf englisch
hat es sich besser anja bruder da
müsstest du aber besseres englisch
schreiben können nicht so wie sonne
sandra da irgendwie imminent ist rod
special take it with us intensiviere
hast du mich an der arbeit abholen vier
fragezeichen morgen nein jetzt tue hat
es doch um 17 uhr feierabend
eingeschlafen
das
ist tatsächlich dann auch wieder zu
300.000 programm nächste nachricht
schreibt ein liebes mädchen namens
nicole an ihren lieben freund namens
nils und zwar schreibt ihr liebe nicole
küsste mich mal lieber als andauernd mit
seinem handy zu spielen
daraufhin antwortet der liebe nils hier
ein kuss für dich nicole und macht einen
kuss meili
könnt ihr diese beziehungen die
irgendwie mehr über das handy social
media whatsapp sms et cetera geführt
werden als in realer ich weiß nicht wie
es bei euch früher war aber bei mir war
es wirklich auch so ich hatte meine
erste freundin glaube ich irgendwie der
dritten klasse und mein erstes handy
nokia 63.000 wirklich so ein richtiges
so kannst du wegschmelzen ist immer noch
heidenspaß also das ding hält wirklich
allem stand ich hatte das handy über
irgendwie 45 jahre oder so das einzige
was ihr passiert das ist hier oben das
ebenso ein bisschen belag abgegangen ist
aber was ich sagen wollte
ich habe meine erste beziehung in der
dritten klasse gehabt allerdings war das
keine richtige beziehung sondern haben
uns quasi man nur so nachrichten
geschrieben aber wenn wir in der schule
waren haben wir es mal so ein bisschen
zu ignorieren und dann auch wenn wir
damals setzen waren dann waren immer so
freude wird dabei das total komisch
irgendwie diese zeit kommen wir nun auch
schon zum letzten watts beziehungsweise
mehr oder weniger halt sms viel für die
heutige folge weil wir eben wie heute
mehr sms fans als models traten aber na
ja auf jeden fall schreibt einen mädchen
an ihren vater kannst du mich eine
stunde später abholen wie noch später
ich muss auch mal schlafen ach bitte es
ist so toll heute ich würde gerne noch
ein bisschen länger bleiben denkst du an
unsere absprache unter der woche nur bis
22 uhr
daraufhin antwortet sie drei frage
zeichnet einen traurigen smiley und der
vater bewegt berichten
der vater berichtet sich und schreit
entschuldige das wollte ich nicht
schreiben es sollte bitte heißen
sorry auch dass ich das wort gerade
wieder gehen musste und youtube ist ein
bisschen pingelig geworden was das ganze
angeht allerdings will ich das heute
wieder in der heutigen episode gefallen
hat und zeigt mit einem daumen hoch über
über ein video wahrscheinlich sehe man
den youtube analytics dass 60 prozent
der leute die sich meine videos
anschauen kein abonnent von meinem kanal
sind von daher das kann ich euch dann
auf jeden fall nicht empfehlen weil
sonst bekommt ihr solche videos dann
demnächst immer oben angezeigt und das
will ja keiner
ciao
[Musik]